ils ont réalisé l'exploit de ce week-end
est probablement celui de la saison les
joueurs du basket club de maurepas et
éliminer l'ogre de nationale 3
barjouville lors du 128e de coupe de
france
évidemment page spéciale à suivre dans
ce set 8 fort bonsoir à tous ravis de
vous retrouver pour ce dernier cette
fuite sport de 2014
on passe tout de suite au titre de cette
émission il est désormais le nouveau
président de la fédération française de
montagne l'entraîneur du ch est née
stéphane geoffrey sera l'invité du 7-8
sport ce soir pour nous expliquer ces
projets et l'avenir qu'il voit pour la
discipline
entre danses acrobaties et gymnastique
la pole dance attire de plus en plus
d'adeptes
loin des clichés de la strip teaseuse et
de ses shows à la barre découverte d'une
discipline de plus en plus populaire
dans les yvelines évidemment vous en
avez l'habitude en fin d'émission le jt
résultats du week end mais place à notre
page spéciale basket
romel le tabouret à l'endroit et non
qu'on parle de basket ce soir évidemment
après ce cet exploit grandeur nature des
joueurs du basket club de maurepas
l'entraîneur est présent sur le plateau
du 7-8 sports accompagné de son
président alexis dumonteil david raza
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être là
alors avant de débriefer cet exploit
parce qu'on peut parler d'exploit
je vous propose de regarder le résumé du
match je le disais donc entre
barjouville est mort pas sur le papier
trois divisions d'écart mais lors de ce
vingtième de coupe de france
la magie de la compétition à opérer dans
un gymnase de la malle me donne en
fusion le bcm a réalisé le plus grand
exploit de son histoire résumée réalisé
avec l ol elodie moines pardon et
florine parfait
il en avait discrètement rêver les
joueurs du bcm l'on réalisé le petit
poucet d'excellence élimine l'ogre de
masse ionale 3 barjouville ans 128e deux
coupes de france attend près d'une heure
et demie plutôt mal me donne n'était pas
aussi confiant s'il est mort payen
débutent la rencontre avec 20 points
d'avancé du fait de l'écart de trois
divisions grâce à une défense très
agressive
les joueurs de ré loix remonte
rapidement leur handicap pour terminer
le premier quart temps à moins 8 34 26
en faveur du bcm
bis repetita dans le deuxième quart
temps le rouleau compresseur de
nationale 3 continue sa marche en avant
à la mi-temps barjouville bascule en
tête avec un petit point d'avancé et
puis commence un jeu de chat et la
souris il chacune leur tour les deux
équipes vont prendre un à cinq points
d'avance poussé par un gymnase de la
malle mode en fusion les joueurs
maurepas siens tiennent la cadence des
visiteurs jusqu'au money time
et cette dernière minute de jeu
irrespirable à 22 secondes du buzzer la
défense du bcm tient bon et obtient une
dernière possession pour repasser devant
et s'offrir la victoire
maurepas s'impose 89 à 87 et réussit là
le plus grand exploit de son histoire en
coupe de france
le rêve peut continuer descriptible
sincèrement qu'ils auraient pu a misé
une pièce sur nous mais bon voilà c'est
classe et un groupe qui travaille dur
toute la saison on est invaincu en
championnat
c'est une récompense une récompense par
rapport à qu'est-ce qu'on travaille
depuis trois ans je vais d'abord me
diriger vers le président quel exploit
dans ce match face à voir jouer
un véritable exploit ça fait du bien de
revoir les images que je me rappelais
pas de la dernière minute
donc ça me permet là vraiment de devoir
l'exploit qu'on a réalisé alexis vous
réalisez en tant qu'entraîneur ce que
vos joueurs ont produit samedi soir tout
doucement tout doucement on a encore du
mal à retomber sur terre c'est c'est
difficile encore à croire au jour
d'aujourd'hui qu'on ait pu éliminer une
équipe de nationale 3 mais bon vous
l'avez fait voilà c'est la magie du
sport c'est c'est le sentiment de fierté
qui domine justement en tant
qu'entraîneur par rapport à votre groupe
oui souvent dur avec eux mais c'est vrai
que là il ya comme une certaine
satisfaction satisfaction et aborder ça
juste avant les fêtes de noël c'est un
beau cadeau pour pour les supporters
pour le club pour la ville parce qu'on a
quand même été vraiment soutenu par 400
personnes aux plus aisés pas arrivé
souvent et on en redemande quoi et
encore évidemment ce prochain tour ce
64e on attend le résultat du tirage au
sort qui était cet après midi on n'en
est pas encore là
le verdict ça va bientôt tomber dans les
prochaines heures david ce qui est
surprenant c'est que dans cette équipe
en fin de compte c'est des purs produits
bcm en fait et ça c'est quand même une
particularité tout à fait plus de 80% de
l'équipe et ce sont vraiment des purs
mort pas iem qui ont commencé le basket
à l'école de basket de maurepas et c'est
vraiment un groupe de copains
c'est le résultat d'un projet à moyen
terme un petit peu cette performance
peut être pas que ses performances vous
êtes aussi premier il faut le dire de
votre championnat en excellence est
invaincu cette saison
c'est la concrétisation
projet le projet à court terme c'était
de se maintenir le fait dans ce
département table et c'est vrai qu'au vu
des résultats
malheureusement peut plus cacher parce
que voilà être invaincu à la trêve
il n'a pas beaucoup qui le réalise voilà
maintenant à l'objectif il est clair
c'est de monter d'un échelon et de
pouvoir jouer sur tous les tableaux
mais la priorité reste le championnat et
de monter au niveau régional la saison
prochaine il va pas falloir confondre
tous les objectifs la coupe de france ça
reste le bonus est cette bouteille
sélection c'est de l'apprentissage c'est
c'est un niveau qu'on n'a pas l'habitude
de rencontrer tous les jours par rapport
aux équipes qu'on affronte le week-end
rien qu'en termes d'entraînement les
abordent différemment c'est que du bonus
ça nous aidera à grandir et je l'espère
je l'espère pour les prochains tours ce
qui est intéressant dans ce match c'est
aussi le fait que vous avez tenu
physiquement face à une équipe de
nationale 3 ça c'était peut-être pas
couru d'avancé avant le début de la
rencontre quand on quand on voit le le
premier carton on se dit que ça va être
très compliqué parce qu'on démarre et 20
points d'avance on essaye d'en faire
abstraction mais on a toujours cette
donc le match commence pas entre
guillemets on sait pas vraiment ce que
sa voie en face et voilà on s'est pris
un 8 0 d'entrée donc 20 à 8 il a fallu
calmer les calmer les choses rapidement
reconcentrés les joueurs mais voilà si
on doute pas si on se donne à fond et
voilà c'est c'est du sport
tout peut arriver tout le monde est égal
à évidemment sur le terrain sur un match
tout peut tout peut se passer
david le public à une part prépondérante
un samedi soir c'était un gymnase en
fusion comme je le disais dans le
reportage
oui tout à fait c'est c'était vraiment
énorme déjà on a un bon public pendant
toute la saison le samedi soir on a
vraiment du monde qui vient encourager
mais alors là samedi soir ç'a dépassé
toutes nos espérances
est ce un beau cadeau pour toute
l'équipe et pour tout le club qui
oeuvrent tout au long de la saison
le bénévole cadre toutes ces équipes et
puis les entraîneurs les joueurs aussi
qui se donne tant sur le terrain alors
évidemment la question qui découle de
cette performance et où vous allez vous
arrêter maintenant parce qu'après avoir
battu nationale 3 on peut on peut
commencer à rêver un petit peu n'en est
pas encore là encore les gens en
attendant s'attendait à avoir des
semaines de vacances pour reprendre le
championnat donc du coup on va reprendre
le week-end du 3 4 janvier donc il va
falloir mettre deux semaines
d'entraînement en pleine pleine fête
c'est pas simple mais
voilà tant que joueur sera opérationnel
pour le prochain match et y'a pas de
soucis ici se donnent ainsi se donne à
fond
y'a pas de raison que ça passe pas très
bien on suivra ça de près évidemment
donc bravo encore au basket club ne mord
pas pour cette superbe performance et
puis rendez-vous au prochain tour pour
peut-être un nouvel exploit à domicile
merci à tous les deux d'être masia sur
le 7-8 sport pour être complet sur les
autres résultats justement des club
yvelinois alors de ceux 128e de coupe de
france vous allez le voir à l'image trap
a fait le job comme on dit sur le
parquet de boston roger en roumois
victoire 91 à 70 c seule défaite du côté
des yvelines c'est sartrouville face à
saint thomas le havre 66 à 52 on
enchaîne avec le cyclisme et à
l'occasion de la signature d'un nouveau
partenariat entre la fédération
française de cyclisme est une marque
automobile tchèque nous nous sommes
arrêtés sur la vie des équipes dans leur
voiture un peu leur seconde maison il
faut le dire pour les coureurs cyclistes
montage de romain rugby déjà partenaire
du tour de france jusqu'en 2018
la marque tchèque signe là un
partenariat pour trois ans avec la
fédération française de cyclisme
des voitures sont un excellent outil est
évidemment technique ça transporte les
vélos celui des coureurs c'est c'est le
repère dans la course puis comme on est
souvent sur les routes on arrive à
dormir dedans on mange dedans c'est un
peu notre deuxième maison
le confort de ces véhicules est donc
essentiel car avec 200 jours de course
et six ans de stage dans l'année pour
toutes les équipes lie à la fédération
quelle que soit la discipline
les tricolores passent beaucoup de temps
sur la route est parfois la vie sur les
sièges peut vite devenir plus attrayante
qu'on ne le croit par exemple à sion
veut en belgique qu'en belgique ou dans
le nord de la france ou n'importe où là
on y va vraiment en voiture et
des forums post ap denver on rigole bien
que la voiture c'est un moment qui peut
être convivial aussi entre coureurs en
devenant voitures officielles de la
fédération française de cyclisme à
partir de 2015
la marque automobile équipera 30
véhicules fédéraux en est on enchaîne
donc on continue avec les informations
cyclisme et à deux mois des mondiaux
justement de cyclisme sur piste à saint
quentin en yvelines nous en avons
profité pour sonder les membres de
l'équipe de france sur leurs sensations
leur forme du moment en vue de la
compétition
et si françois pervis se retrouvent tous
du tout juste 1 du jus après avoir été
malade de son côté kévin sireau attend
le 18 février 2015 avec un patient
moi qui tombait jamais malade
l'apprendre de trois semaines trois
quatre semaines d'antibiotiques ça m'a
vraiment coupé en deux mais donc
l'entraînement à l'entraînement
impossible de m'entraîner correctement
jean-loup paix où je faisais un quart
est le cas que je faisais n'était pas
bien fait donc j'étais vraiment vraiment
rincer mais là je suis content parce que
ça revient c'est la deuxième semaine que
je que je fais où je sens vraiment que
les ouates et reviennent et que j'ai de
bonnes gens
la puissance revient c'est vraiment la
fierté qui prime
on est à la maison on va voir du public
les places sont vendues très très vite
donc on sait qu'il y avoir beaucoup de
monde qui va bien nous soutenir
on est content et on attend avec
impatience ce moment là où ou le frisson
quand les gens nous applaudir de
m'encourager pour pour aller le plus
vite et donner le meilleur de nous-mêmes
mais il est le nouvel homme fort de la
fédération française de muay thaï
l'entraîneur du team chase au chesnay
stéphane geoffrey a été élu début
décembre
il ya quelques jours président de cette
entité il est sûre le 7-8 sport ce soir
pour nous expliquer ses projets sa
raison de cette élection
bonsoir à vous stéphane merci non c'est
dangereux la première question pourquoi
avoir choisi de postuler à ce poste de
président par la force des choses parce
que bon vous êtes au courant un petit
peu de la situation pour la fédération
il se trouve que la fédération donc life
mda a subi un préjudice de 200 mille
euros par rapport à des dirigeants qui
sont un peu malfaisants et qui sont
partis clairement avec la caisse jacques
mairesse exactement non il faut l'ifo
est nécessaire il faut le site et
puisque c'était un haut représentant et
on avait confiance et malheureusement
c'est une trahison aujourd'hui un
préjudice qu'on subit à tort à tort est
bon vous êtes conscient que justement
vous reprenez une fédération qui est
minée par ces conflits qui est un petit
peu détruites entre guillemets c'est
c'est pourquoi je me suis jamais
impliqué dans la politique sportive
parce que je sais qu'il ya un double
intérêt il ya l'intérêt du sport et
l'intérêt personnel finalement c'est
toujours le grand dilemme sport business
finalement et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
de reprendre la fédération sous forme de
collégiale de manière horizontale et non
vertical avec une équipe de venez de
bénévoles qui qui qui proviennent du
terrain puisqu'ils ont ils ont longtemps
travaillé avec moi sur le terrain
et de pouvoir ajouter des forces
complémentaires pour créer une unité
c'est quelque chose qui devrait relever
très très rapidement la fédération
française de montagne aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qui a fait changer un peu votre
position votre opinion parce que vous le
disiez souvent s'étaient déjà rencontrés
lors de reportages vous me disiez
toujours je vais m'investir et pas dans
une fédération qu'est-ce qui a qui a
fait le basculement de le basculement
c'est qu'aujourd'hui je sais avec telle
équipe je pars donc je connais mes
atouts majeurs qui sont momo mon corps
mon corps de travail qui n'est
représentée que par des bénévoles et
qu'ils n'ont aucun intérêt financier et
personnel au sein de la fédération et je
pense que ce monsieur mairesse en
partant avec les deux cent mille euros a
oublié les principes fondamentaux d'une
association sportive une fédération
c'est une association qui a pour but de
représenter les les membres de la
fédération
les clubs existants les cotisants à
savoir les sportifs pour le bien du
sport amateur et par la suite le sport
professionnel avec un point d'équilibré
il s'agit de faire respecter par rapport
à vos projets parce que maintenant
évidemment vous êtes élu vous êtes
président de cette fédération il ya un
plan de redressement qui est prévue est
ce que par exemple lors la récupération
de l'agrément ministériel c'est une
valeur priorité très bonne chose j'ai
été élu il ya deux semaines en deux
semaines d'énormes efforts et un énorme
travail a été effectué et d'elin sur le
terrain on est en mesure de dire qu'on
peut on peut continuer les compétitions
fédérales puisque le retrait de
l'agrément n'empêche pas le la
continuité de l'activité
nous sommes affiliés aujourd'hui à la
fédération de kempo qui nous représente
en tant qu'art martiaux et nous pouvons
nous sommes en mesure d'assurer les
compétitions fédérales pour l'année 2015
tout parallèlement en créant un dossier
politique pour récupérer l'agrément
auprès de auprès du ministère
finalement et leur montrer qu'il ya un
réel potentiel
exactement il ya dix mille adhérents à
gérer dix mille adhérents en attente
il ya une représentation de la fmda à
l'international chose que n'a pas la
fédération délégataire qui représente le
côté nationale des choses donc il ya une
force à faire valoir une vraie valeur
ajoutée pour cette fédération et outre
l'agrément ministériel qui est une
priorité est évidemment il ya des
projets à moyen terme ou parce que comme
vous assurez a priori un intérim de ce
qui se dit dans le monde du muay-thaï
vous voulez c'est le moyen terme à votre
successeur déjà exactement alors le
monde du muay-thaï nous considère comme
des intérêts des intérimaires plus que
nous représentons pas la forme la forme
archaïque des choses à savoir un
président et ses disciples
nous sommes là pour montrer qu' il est
temps de passer à autre chose à une
autre une autre forme structurel de
fédération comme de nombreux pays ont pu
l'adopter
maintenant et nous allons réussir danse
danse dans ce sens là nous avons le
week-end dernier déjà organisé les
championnats nationaux da soit technique
et de combat le plan de redressement est
déjà entamée puisque nous avons
échelonné la dette et ventiler la dette
à cet effet nous sommes en mesure de
reprendre une petite fédération de
refaire maintient là exactement cac qui
devient qui redeviendra grande par la
suite merci beaucoup stéphane chez nous
on peut placer sur ce set 8 couronnes
avec évidemment au team chahid bourg du
terrain et de l'entraînement merci avec
stéphane on enchaîne sans transition
paul baysse je vous en parlais dans les
titres entre danses acrobaties et
gymnastique la pole dance attire de plus
en plus d'amateurs est loin des clichés
de la strip teaseuse de ses shows à la
barre cette discipline se populariser
devient un véritable sport à part
entière yolaine thorez et elodie moines
ont rencontré quelques pratiquante du
côté de versailles
le fireman le jimmy nay le bird ou
encore le rock star les figures
s'enchaînent autour de la barre
verticale
bienvenue dans le monde de la pole dance
pour hélène professeurs ici à versailles
depuis quatre ans il s'agit d'un
véritable sport à part entière
mélange d'acrobaties de danse et de
créativité la pole dance eux se
rapprochent notamment du cirque ou de la
gym mais pas seulement c'est aussi une
expression corporelle comme la danse où
je peux pas aller jusqu'au théâtre parce
que c'est là on n'est pas dans un jeu
vraiment mais vraiment ça en fait ça
fait ressortir de la personnalité aussi
et des fois même un peu la gestuelle est
caractère de la personne
le cours commence d'abord par un
échauffement et à peu primordial pour
préparer les muscles et les
articulations
le but est d' alors j'ai en fait son but
est d'aller loin devant les danseuses
travail ensuite les figures à la barre
la première qualité pour réussir n'est
pas nécessairement d'être très musclé ou
très souple mais surtout de savoir faire
preuve d'un peu de patience
il ya des choses qu'on aimerait faire
qui sont pas forcément toujours
accessible et mais en fait si on
écoutait si on a envie d'avancer de
tester des choses et qu'on prend en
compte tous les conseils
on voit les choses surtout dans le bon
ordre avec la bonne technique et c'est
finalement ça fonctionne au queen un job
de denner va ramer et là on va passer le
projet qui on va piloter en boule et
après on va frapper là où j'aime bien le
côté physique c'est vraiment très très
sportif on se muscle vachement vite et
puis le côté artistique
il ya beaucoup de discipline qui mêle
vraiment les deux cas c'est à la fois
plaisant mais en même temps on a fait
tous travailler c'est sympa on est entre
filles on s'amuse beaucoup et puis voilà
c'est un vrai plaisir
on a tendance à vouloir faire les choses
en force alors qu'en réalité lorsqu'on a
compris la technique ça c'est plus une
force et ça devient quelque chose de
beaucoup plus simple
longtemps associé au monde de la nuit au
striptease la pole dance eux se
développe de plus en plus comme une
véritable discipline sportive
aujourd'hui des championnats de france
sont organisées et des écoles fleuriste
un peu partout la jambe de devant à
l'horaire il sera derrière m on n'entend
plus les gens sont ouverts et moi on en
a eu assez de strip tease tu vas t'on
club laisse trépied c'est moins tabou
les femmes osent veut dire que voilà
qu'elles ne font que c'est un vrai sport
voilà elle avait frappé deux fois le met
même en avant ou encore petit à petit on
ne parlera pas la conquête comme ça une
conquête qui ne s'arrête pas qu'aux
femmes minoritaires pour le moment
certains hommes commencent aussi à s'y
mettre
avec le jt résultats du week end et ont
commencé quelques résultats de ce
week-end de fin décembre par du tennis
de table et 0 sur 2 pour l encours en
proa cette semaine se jouait les 8e et
9e journée mardi
le cet été s'est logiquement incliné à
metz 4 points à 0 et ensuite au palais
des sports pour le compte de la 9e
journée des joueuses de franck sony
n'ont rien pu faire face aux quatrièmes
saint-quentin défaites 4 points à un
seul eva odorova a sauvé l'honneur et
vous allez le voir
au classement ces deux journées
rapprochée ont fait mal à elancourt les
joueuses de franck saunier se retrouve
désormais septième avec 16 points alors
qu'elle était tout proche du podium il
ya quelques semaines en haut du
classement metz est leader avec 26
points
football championnat de division
d'honneur et match en retard de la 11e
journée pour cause de coupe de france
fin de série pour versailles qui
s'incline sur le terrain du 2e saint
maur lusitano ce de but à 0 une défaite
qui n'a que peu de conséquences il faut
le dire au classement puisque versailles
conserve sa troisième place de cette
poule de dh avec 34 points à sept
longueurs de leur adversaire du jour
passée en tête avec 41 points ce
week-end le bushido club de trappes
recevait les championnats régionaux de
taekwondo d'île de france
évidemment compétition qualificative
pour les championnats nationaux 2015 les
six premiers de chaque catégorie sont
retenus pour l'étape nationale trois
combattants de trappes étaient engagés
en juniors seniors et vétérans
malheureusement peu de réussite pour
issam arraché ni chez les moins de 63 kg
enseigne c'est un premier combat à
élimination directe m'adore
premier pas
j'ai pas su le mettre dans le combat
comme il le fallait
j'étais un peu surpris par parler
technique de l'adversaire
malheureusement c'est pas pâti le niveau
globalement et à saïd b sur des
championnats régionaux qualificatifs
aussi un temps chaque année des gens
bien pour ce soir de façon
et pour issam rachid il lui restera tout
de même l'option des tournois labellisés
les open pour tenter d'obtenir son
ticket en vue de ces fameux championnat
de france c'est la fin de ce sept huit
sports dernier 7,8 sport 2014
merci encore une fois de l'avoir suivi
je vous souhaite d'excellentes fêtes de
fin d'année excellente soirée également
sur tv fille